hace 40 años tome crisis lucharon en la
misma guerra hoy los une una larga
amistad y la misma familia de veteranos
en ese entonces crisis su oficial de la
armada navegaba el elche meses coventry
mientras se entrenaban gibraltar su
barco duró una semana en llegar a aguas
del atlántico sur y el 25 de mayo de
1982 la embarcación fundida tras ser
impactada con tres bombas fueron which
una de las cuales me causa un daño grave
el 27 por ciento de mi cuerpo se quemó
pude salir del barco y lamentablemente
19 de mis compañeros fallecieron ese día
mientras que toma sargento del ejército
cruzó a pie las islas durante una semana
en el terreno es bastante inhóspito el
clima es duro era invierno el suelo
estaba húmedo y pantanoso y consiste en
muchos montículos de rocas que no puedes
cruzar no importa lo que hagas tienes
que rodear a la costa
el 14 de junio de 1982 el último día de
la guerra don recuerda que inicialmente
fue un día más de combate
era euforia pero también tristeza porque
sabíamos que algunos de nuestros
camaradas no habían visto ese día era un
costo y nunca nunca se recuperaría
pero chris no tiene memoria de ese día
estaba luchando por su vida en un
hospital de montevideo pero una
reflexión ha permanecido intacta desde
entonces sabe y es para mí la guerra y
el conflicto son algo terrible y se debe
hacer todo lo posible para evitar un
conflicto abierto has visto lo que está
pasando en ucrania en este momento
los dos ha regresado a las islas en
diferentes aniversarios mientras que
otros veteranos han vuelto por su salud
mental es un tipo algunas personas
necesitan que sus fantasmas descansen
algunas personas que quieran regresar y
ver donde perdieron a sus camaradas y
recordarlos correctamente 'el nacional'
armin y siempre salta en una exposición
la valentía de los veteranos y también
la transformación para los isleños
la guerra fue increíble para las islas
falkland y al ser casi olvidadas por el
gobierno británico se volvieron muy
importante para asegurarse de que se
escucharan las voces de la gente en este
aniversario también recuerda después de
una guerra tan dura sigue la disputa
sobre la soberanía de las islas